Jason Momoa is getting his family into
the holiday spirit as he drops off a
Christmas tree at his ex-wife Lisa
bonet's house he's trying to be a
gentleman that's the actor holding a
rope getting ready to tie down the
Norway spruce tree he then loaded it up
to the bed of his truck and later
brought it to Lisa with whom he shares
two children fifteen-year-old Lola and
14 year old nicoa wolf Jason's delivery
a good sign the two are co-parenting
smoothly following their split in
January having a strong woman standing
by your side I mean we support each
other in all the Arts and what our
endeavors are Jason and Lisa's breakup
came after 16 years together and five
years of marriage A source told E.T at
the time the two were struggling in
their relationship for some time quote
when Jason was away filming Aquaman 2
their differences and issues were
heightened he was gone for a while and
it definitely put additional stress on
their relationship despite going their
separate ways the source added they
still have love for each other and
respect one another it's beautiful to go
through so many different
challenges in our lives and have a
partner that loves you through all of it
and the X's have shown just that since
they're split back in March Jason and
the kids stepped out to support Lisa's
daughter Zoe Kravitz at the premiere for
her film The Batman we're just so proud
you know money can be here a little
quick you know Lisa couldn't be here so
we're representing me and the babies and
so we're very excited
to just be here then in November Jason
left a bunch of heart emojis on Zoe's
dad Lenny Kravitz's birthday post for
Lisa the two were previously married
from 1987 to 1993. looking out for each
other for sure and that kind of family
love comes as no surprise a source-old
ET in May the former couple wants to
keep things friendly quote Jason and
Lisa are still committed to being
friends for the sake of their family
they both want each other to be happy
foreign